did you ever think that said bladder was
actually going to go voluntarily if you
can call this voluntarily yeah I didn't
think he was going to go voluntarily
that's for sure but I certainly think
what has happened is absolutely a
reflection of the sponsors and the true
stakeholders in this organization the
fact of FIFA has been set up as a one
vote one country kind of arrangement for
so long has allowed Seth bladder to a
masters kind of power in this situation
I think FIFA is absolutely correct at
looking at restructuring and putting in
term limits I think that's the right
thing to do miss Weaver it's mark
crumpton I had to ask because you just
mentioned that set bladder had amassed
this type of power is it possible that
we could see going forward of FIFA where
the power is not held by one person but
perhaps via committee yeah I think so
and I think that's exactly what the
executive committee is saying right now
is we need to take charge of this so
that this kind of situation doesn't
develop within our entire executive
structure and that's really what I'm
concerned about right now is it a cloth
the executive structure there was this
allowance of infiltration and influence
across so many levels of the
organization and I think the executive
committee absolutely will need to take
much more struggle much more power here
Karen a lot of people going to be
blowing the dust off the covers of their
FIFA reform plans that they never
thought would work what would such a
plan look like if you were allowed to
write it well it would certainly I think
take into account the changing dynamics
of the world game I don't think it would
all go back to the European power base
which is exactly what people wanted to
get away from but I think they would
strongly look at trying to balance out
the the regions of the world and trying
to look at more of a regional structure
rather than a one country one vote
because right now it's too easy for the
Cayman Islands for example to influence
policy as it is for Germany and that
right now doesn't really reflect the
strengths of the numbers of participants
in the world game